olivia and val talk to me first and
foremost
how do you feel right now how's the
situation
where your mind
been better yeah pretty bombed okay but
honestly this has been the best
experience and i'm so happy we made it
this far and i'm just really glad we got
to dance i mean it wasn't even we said
this from the start it wasn't about
winning or losing we just wanted to go
the distance to you know have the chance
to dance as much as possible so i'm
bummed that that's coming to an end but
i got a forever friend and some new
moves
[Music]
talk to me about your confidence this
thing built your confidence do you feel
like a new person does it what did it do
for you internally honestly yeah i've
said it before but i just feel like very
proud of something now and i put in so
much work and the rehearsals and the
stuff that a lot of people don't see
just the constant work ethic you have to
have to be on this show so
um yeah i just felt like the sense of
pride
that's awesome that's awesome let's talk
janet all right i came up i was like
part of the janet generation it was like
a big part of my life talk to me about
dancing to janet did you enjoy that was
it a good song for you
yeah i thought it was so much fun i mean
she's an icon obviously everybody killed
it it was so fun to watch everybody
perform and i thought it was cool too
because we just did something different
and it was a little bit i feel like more
mature than my other dances and i'm
really proud of that so good it
literally was so good it breaks my heart
that you guys aren't it just kills me i
know it's insane
uh tell me about dad dad danced in a
janet video what did not dance no
but he was in a he was in a janitor
[Music]
he was in it for like three seconds he's
in like a truck i think he's in his
probably like late 20s but yeah they
were just friends in the early 90s so
she just asked him to be a part of it
and
the rest is history then i exposed him
on national tv
he actually just texted me after and he
was just saying like i'm really honored
you would even put me in
did you already text him that you guys
were voted out tonight yeah oh no what
did he say well i think he knew from
other people because he texted me just
like i love you you killed it i'm so
proud of you regardless no he's so proud
honestly like
i'm just so grateful i made it this far
and it was such an experience i i
honestly don't even have words to like
explain how grateful i am so it is
certainly a life-changing experience
[Music]
let's talk about the judge's reactions
for a second the judges said they wanted
more heat i felt the heat for one and
len didn't like the table let's just
talk about that for a second what's your
guys take on len not liking the table
well val said it best don't knock it
till you try it len clearly hasn't
encountered many tables
period
that's right that's right i want to talk
the dance off score and the whole
situation with the dance-off
first of all how did you guys feel about
the dance i i thought again you nailed
it so where
yeah good i mean we were facing some
tough competitions so
but we gave it our all yeah and we and i
had to learn two new dances which was
very challenging this week and
so i feel like i really just gave it my
all and that's all i can do no regrets
i think you know you guys said
it was the furthest
you've made it in four seasons val said
right is the furthest we made it in four
seasons let's talk about that it has
been
one of my favorite seasons i've ever
done on the show and i've done i think
17 seasons yeah
and yeah it's been the furthest i've
i've gone and i think four years which
is so exciting but
again i'm bummed i'm sad
because i
don't get to spend every day
with with this young lady i mean she's
extraordinary she's a she's wonderful
she's you know perfect teammate perfect
student so
i had a blast
teaching her how to dance and i had a
blast dancing this season
and you guys got friends for life out of
this hell yes which is crucially
important i love that
when you first heard
the judge's reaction you're going home
was it truly shocking did you think that
that may have happened to you or did you
feel high after dancing tonight
i still don't know if i processed it
because i feel like i'm so used to
coming and rehearsing every day so it's
gonna just feel very different and weird
and i'm so sad but i feel like i also
know that this show is just like i can
never predict what's going to happen and
so
i don't think that i was expecting to
make it to semis or finals but it's
something i would have really loved to
accomplish so